Right. So I said we have two types of data structures.
We have arrays in which elements are put in
some.
linear order
and arrays are very you there pervasive
right many things come
in tabular form in the form of rows and columns. That's how we store data
a lot but not always and they're this particular type
of data structure. It's not appropriate in every situation.
The second time is the graph to the structure a subset of
which is a tree it is structure. Now. This is a graph.
And very quickly, let me introduces to some terms.
These circles we call the vertices.
Or they go by another synonym nodes. So
these are either nodes. You can call them
nodes if you want.
Or you can call them vertices now, you can see
that we have these lines that go from one vertex to
another.
These lines we call edges.
So very simply put a graph.
is
compose of two things a set
of vertices
and the set of edges and the
edges are the connections.
between the verses vertices
Now, of course if you see here, we also have this Edge that
comes back to the same vertex.
Understanding graphs are also allowed to understand something called
finite State machines finite State machines are
at the center of many things.
from vending machines
to
physics
regular expressions
and
If you're not familiar with regular expressions.
It is a form of programming.
And it is Central to applications like
a natural language processing and natural language
understanding.
Moreover and also another application
of graphs or being able to understand graphs
is building complex stateful
machines.
A complex you applications with very
complex user interfaces.
require
States there's something called a state
that is well formalized and
it has to be something that is well planned ahead of time.
If you want to be able to build such applications.
with very, you know
elaborate
User Journeys. Well then.
You need to be able to formulate these
mathematically.
and once again
the
mathematical subject that discusses such ideas is
discrete mathematics.